[موسيقى]
حدث انفجار في
الاختراقات التكنولوجية في السنوات
الأخيرة ،
لكن المبتكرين والمبدعين
هم الذين يحلمون بالتطبيقات العملية
لهذه الاختراقات التكنولوجية
التي تفكر حقًا في إنجاز كبير
يجد الكثيرون أنه قد حان
للابتكار وهو الطباعة ثلاثية الأبعاد
مثل هذا المركز الذي كان  تم بناؤه
باستخدام التكنولوجيا
[الموسيقى
] وهنا في دبي ، هناك عدد من
الشركات التي تستخدم التكنولوجيا لمتابعة
أفكارهم الكبيرة ،
كان تومي الشوا من أوائل
المتبنين لهذه التكنولوجيا
في عام 2016.
فكرتنا الكبيرة هي
تعطيل النفط والغاز تمامًا  عمل في مجال قطع الغيار
، وضع نصب عينيه قطاعًا ضخمًا
من قطع الغيار من الصواميل والمسامير إلى الملحقات المعدنية
والصمامات المستخدمة لاستبدال الأجزاء القديمة أو المكسورة
والمعدات ،
إنه قطاع ضخم بمليارات
الدولارات ، طبيعة قطع الغيار هي أنها موضوعة على
الرفوف  يقوم الأشخاص بتخزين قطع الغيار في حالة
حدوث عطل ويحتاجون إلى استخدامها حتى
يكونوا أصولاً غير فعالة وغير
مستخدمة.  يتم سحبها عندما تكون مطلوبة ،
وأعتقد أن هذا من الطراز القديم للغاية ،
أعني بالتكنولوجيا ، لا ينبغي أن يكون هذا هو
الحال
باستخدام مجموعة من الطابعات ثلاثية الأبعاد ، فقد
بدأ في طباعة قطع الغيار
فقط عندما تكون هناك حاجة للطباعة ثلاثية الأبعاد
تكون
أكثر رقمية وحديثة  طريقة
تصنيع
[موسيقى]
النفط والغاز هي صناعة ضخمة
وأكثر من ذلك في المنطقة
أن قطع الغيار التي تنفق على النفط والغاز
سنويًا في جميع أنحاء العالم تتجاوز 160
مليار
دولار وكمية الهدر من
الاستهلاك
في قطع الغيار ضخمة
للأسرة وله  يقوم فريق من المهندسين
ببناء مكتبة رقمية
تهدف إلى الحصول على نسخة من كل قطعة
غيار في النفط والغاز
وتخزين الصور في السحابة
واستخدام الطباعة ثلاثية الأبعاد
لتكرارها ، ولكنه
يستخدم أيضًا التكنولوجيا لدفع
الحدود
إلى ما هو ممكن تقليديًا هذا
هو جزء
مستهلك يستخدم الفولاذ الكربوني وأي
مصفاة ستستهلك المئات منها شهريًا
بطباعة ثلاثية الأبعاد تمكنا من استبدال
المواد التقليدية  تعمل بالتيتانيوم
على إطالة العمر الافتراضي بمقدار
الضعف تقريبًا من أربع سنوات إلى ثماني
سنوات ،
ونحن الآن في الواقع نقوم بتحسينه بشكل
أكبر باستخدام مواد بلاستيكية عالية الأداء
يمكنها تحمل درجات حرارة تصل إلى 300
درجة
مئوية وتكلف جزءًا صغيرًا من
الطريقة التقليدية وأسرع بكثير
للقيام بتقنية تخريبية ، فإن الطباعة ثلاثية الأبعاد
توفر
تكاليف الوقت وإهدارها
وتحدث ثورة في الصناعة التحويلية
[الموسيقى]
وفقًا لشركة الاستثمار ، من
المقرر أن تنمو الطباعة ثلاثية الأبعاد
بمعدل سنوي مذهل من 12
مليار دولار في العام الماضي
إلى 120 مليار دولار بحلول عام 2025  .
رؤية هذه العائلة المحتملة لديها طموحات كبيرة ،
نريد أن نكون الأكبر في العالم ،
فنحن نريد أن يكون لدينا أكبر
مكتبة للأجزاء الرقمية للنفط والغاز
جاهزة للطباعة
[الموسيقى]
عندما يتعلق الأمر بالطباعة ثلاثية الأبعاد ، يتم ترك القليل من القطاعات
وراءها وهي  السبب الذي جعل جوليان كالاهان
ترك وظيفته
في استشارات النفط والغاز ، شعرت نوعًا ما بعدم الإنجاز ،
أردت أن أجعله ملموسًا  الأشياء التي
كانت لها قيمة حقيقية
للناس وللمجتمع ،
اشتريت أول طابعة تم
تثبيتها في فبراير
2017 ومن هناك
أضفنا طابعات وقمنا بإضافة
برامج وقمنا ببناء الأعمال. ما هي فكرتي الكبيرة
الفكرة الكبيرة هي استخدام الطباعة ثلاثية الأبعاد
لتخصيص الرعاية الطبية لكل شخص
يعمل في مستشفى رائد في
دبي ، وقد أدخل الطباعة ثلاثية الأبعاد في
العمليات الجراحية المعقدة عبر أربعة
مستشفيات ، وتبدأ العملية ببيانات المريض
في شكل CT
أو التصوير بالرنين المغناطيسي وما هي هذه البيانات  بالنظر إلى
داخل المريض مباشرةً ، فهو ينظر
إلى العظام وينظر إلى
الأعضاء ، كل ما تريد رؤيته ،
لدينا رؤية كاملة
داخل المريض ، ثم نقوم بإدخال ذلك في البرنامج
، ثم ننتقل إلى عملية طباعة ثلاثية الأبعاد ،
وهنا أمر مثير للاهتمام حقًا  الحالة
التي أجريناها مؤخرًا
مع فريق جراحة الدماغ في
مستشفى راشد ويمكنك أن ترى أن هذه في الواقع
حالة ورم ورم في
المخ والمريض لديه ورم عميق
يجب أن يخضع لعملية جراحية  لقد أزلنا الآن
ما فعلناه هنا هو أننا أنتجنا
نسخة طبق الأصل تشريحية دقيقة للمريض
وهذا يسمح للجراح بالتدرب
قبل الجراحة ، ويسمح له بالعمل
مع فريقه
لتحديد النهج الذي يريدون اتباعه.
في هذه الجراحة ،
أخذوا معهم نموذجًا مطبوعًا ثلاثي الأبعاد إلى غرفة العمليات
حتى يتمكنوا من استخدامه
للتوجيه أثناء الإجراء
[موسيقى] ،
تحقق التكنولوجيا
فوائد مثبتة وفقًا لدراسة عام 2019
نُشرت في
علم الأشعة الأكاديمي باستخدام تقنية ثلاثية الأبعاد
في العمليات الجراحية المعقدة
يرى 62 دقيقة أقل من الوقت الذي يقضيه في غرف
العمليات
والذي يمكن أن يوفر أكثر من 3700 لكل
عملية جراحية
مع مزيد من الابتكار يرى كلانان
مستقبلًا مشرقًا ومتزايدًا
للطباعة ثلاثية الأبعاد في مجال الرعاية الصحية.
أكثر وأكثر
تخصيصًا ، أصبح أحد التطورات الرئيسية
الآن هو الطباعة الحيوية
وهذا يستخدم تصميمات خاصة بالمريض على سبيل المثال
لطباعة جلد جديد من أجل pa  المرضى
الذين يعانون من حروق شديدة
أو يطبعون العظام للمرضى الذين أصيبوا
بالسرطان واستأصلوا العظام
أو تعرضوا لحوادث سيئة ،
نود المشاركة
في الطباعة الحيوية في المستقبل القريب إذا استطعنا
الحصول على التكنولوجيا المناسبة والتي تناسب
كفاءاتنا الأساسية  عمل
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
لك